♪ ♪
>> Sean: PROTEST, THE
ST. LOUIS PARK, MINNESOTA,
CITY COUNCIL RECONSIDERING A
DECISION TO DO AWAY WITH THE
PRESIDENT
DOMINIC PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
BEFORE MEETINGS.
THE COUNCIL CLAIMED IT WAS
CREATING A MORE WELCOMING
ENVIRONMENT TO A DIVERSE
COMMUNITY BY GETTING READY TO
MAKE RID OF THE PLEDGE.
I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT WE
LIVE IN THE GREATEST COUNTRY GOD
GAVE MAN BUT APPARENTLY NOT.
WE SENT LAWRENCE JONES TO
ST. LOUIS PARK TO ASK PEOPLE
THEY ARE WHAT THEY THOUGHT.
THAT COUNCIL, TAKE A LOOK.
>> IN ST. LOUIS PARK, THEY ARE
GETTING RID OF THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE BEFORE THE
CITY COUNCIL MEETINGS.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THIS?
>> PRETTY HORRIBLE.
AREN'T WE A PART OF A GOVERNMENT
THAT SHOULD BE DOING THAT?
>> PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPINIONS ABOUT.
>> I DON'T HAVE TO SAY THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
I WANT RESPECT BEING TAUGHT TO
PEOPLE, WHETHER THEY ARE SAYING
WORDS, IT'S MORE ACTIONS.
>> THE ST. LOUIS PARK
CITY COUNCIL SAYS THAT THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE SHOULDN'T
BE THERE.
YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> NO, EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS IT.
>> I THINK WE CAN ALL IDENTIFY
AS AMERICANS AND WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THE SAME TRUE VALUES
AND AT THE HEART OF THAT IS
DEMOCRACY.
>> THEY SAY IS NOT REFLECTIVE OF
THE VALUES OF THE COMMUNITY TO,
NOT DIVERSE ENOUGH.
>> I MAY BE OLD-SCHOOL BUT I'M
NOT SURE I AGREE WITH THAT.
>> MY SON IS IN THE CUB SCOUTS,
THEY STILL DO IT.
MY HUSBAND IS IN THE MILITARY,
HE STAND FOR THE FLAG, YOU
SHOULD BE DOING THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE.
>> Sean: A MORE WELCOMING
ENVIRONMENT TO SERVE A DIVERSE
COMMUNITY.
IT'S THE GREATEST COUNTRY GOD
GAVE MAN.
LAWRENCE JONES, HE HAS MORE
FREQUENT FLYER MILES THAN ANYONE
ELSE IN THE NETWORK.
BUT SERIOUSLY, THERE SHOULD BE
ONE THING WE AGREE ON BUT IT IS
NOT THE CASE.
THERE HAS ALWAYS BEEN THE BLAME
AMERICA FIRST CROWD.
NOW THERE IS THE HATE AMERICA
CONTINGENCY OUT THERE AND I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHY.
WHAT COUNTRY WITH A PREFER WE
MODEL?
>> YES, WE ARE SITTING HERE
RIGHT NOW OUTSIDE OF ST. LOUIS
CITY HALL BEHIND US WHERE
PATRIOTS DESCENDED THERE AND
SAID LOOK, IT ONLY TAKES 15
SECONDS TO SAY THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE.
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A LIBERAL
TOWN, SO YOU HAVE REACTION.
SOME LIBERAL SAID WE WANT TO GET
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE, SOME
OF THEM SAYS IT IS
DISCRIMINATORY TOWARDS CITIZENS
IN THIS COUNTRY.
TO THE LINE IS THIS, WE HAVE
ISSUES IN AMERICA BUT AT THE END
OF THE DAY, WE SHOULD BE UNITED
ON THE CAUSES OF AMERICA.
IT'S THE CONSTITUTION THAT GIVES
US SO MUCH PROTECTION.
THIS STARTS ON THE COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
THERE IS A GROWING MOVEMENT OF
PROFESSORS AND ACADEMICS
TEACHING THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AND
THE PUBLIC AT LARGE TO HATE
AMERICA.
>> Sean: THEY DON'T EVEN TEACH
AMERICAN HISTORY.
SPEAK OUT AND IT'S SUCH A
SLANTED VIEW.
>> Sean: LOOK AT THE REACTION
FOR THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
FOURTH OF JULY HONORING OF
AMERICA.
THAT'S THE MILITARY THAT BEAT
COMMUNISM, FASCISM, IMPERIAL
JAPAN AND NAZISM, AND I'M
THINKING WOW, HAVE WE REALLY
FORGOTTEN THAT THIS COUNTRY IS
AS GREAT -- THERE HAS NEVER BEEN
A COUNTRY IN THE HISTORY OF MAN
THAT HAS ACCUMULATED MORE POWER
AND ABUSED IT LESS THAN THE
UNITED STATES?
WE ARE NOT PERFECT AND I WOULD
ADD THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A
COUNTRY THAT HAS ACCUMULATED
MORE POWER AND USED IT TO
ADVANCE THE HUMAN CONDITION THEN
THIS ONE.
YOU CAN'T SAY A PLEDGE?
>> THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
THERE IS A DISTURBING TREND WE
KEEP ON SEEING AND WE HAVE TO
WONDER WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
WE CAN'T EVEN SAY THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE?
WHAT IS IT ABOUT THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE THAT INFURIATES
PEOPLE SO MUCH?
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL --
FOR ALL, NOT FOR SOME PEOPLE,
BUT FOR ALL.
HOW THAT IS NOT INCLUSIVE AND
DIVERSE IS BEYOND ME.
WE HAVE TO GET TO THIS POINT
WHERE WE START TO APPRECIATE WHO
WE ARE AS AMERICANS AND WHAT
BRINGS US TOGETHER.
IT IS NOT NECESSARILY GEOGRAPHIC
AREA, IT IS NOT SKIN COLOR,
RELIGION, ETHNICITY, IT IS THE
RED, WHITE, AND BLUE BEARD AND
THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS THAT
CONNECT US APPEAR TO SOME OF
THOSE THINGS ARE THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE, THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM, WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THOSE TRADITIONS, THEY
MATTER.
SPEAK AT THE BOTTOM LINE IS
WHERE ARE THESE PEOPLE GOING TO
GO IF THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE